this drove me crazy i know i can tell i
can already tell you wound up boy i'm
wound the [ __ ] up
okay i thought that there's a very
organic symbiotic relationship
between ig thoughts and me
okay right what's that relationship the
relationship is
you thought it up and i
objectify that seems like it's not just
a relationship with you
it seems like it's the relationship
relationship right
yeah i'm a great strong faithful man
correct i look at a couple of these
thoughts but you don't search for them
they just pop up
they pop up i also follow sometimes
i don't follow anything new it's been
grandfathered in yeah okay
and honestly some of them they get um
sent to the wayside
i've unfollowed yep do you know what i
mean i'll only keep the
top shelf look at that
for my relationship you know i would
never disrespect my girl by following
new
yeah new is crazy that's crazy but if i
carried it in you knew this about me and
it's like a it's like a friendship
almost
except we've been together for years
i've been following these girls in their
swimwear
brands they're trying to get off the
ground for years okay
every ig thought got a swimwear brand
mark yep they would be so upset to lose
you as a follower they would
be upset to lose me as a follower right
because i thought the relationship was
you [ __ ] it up i objectify the
sluttiness ladies listen right now tell
me if i'm off
taylor listen to me right now tell me if
i'm up there's girls they're literally
posting the most salacious sexualized
pictures you could possibly imagine
okay okay okay i observe
because they are salacious and sexual
okay that's
fair that's fair everybody's happy happy
maybe the occasional double tap to raise
their self-esteem which is clearly low
i would never do such a thing but if i
do be as i'm trembling as i'm looking at
it might happen
that's a terrifying second bro when you
double tap my accident
oh you know you're looking first thing
in the morning your fingers haven't woke
up yet
you're just scrolling through you're
like on tap before your girl wake up
your thumbs are mad horny
she's right here okay
this is the problem i have yeah when
the ig thoughts can't accept
their role in the ecosystem you monetize
the thottiness
i'm okay if you embrace that right
horrible decisions embraces it it's
beautiful
beautiful it's happy it's great they own
the word [ __ ]
correct i'm following these thoughts
that i thought were on the same page
okay i thought they were i thought they
understood
you are objectifying yourself and i will
objectify you in return as you wish
right
i see a post today from one of them
the post says stop
this is some quote [ __ ] you know they
love leave them quotes
they love these quotes it goes stop
sexualizing the naked female
wait for it stop sexualizing the naked
female the female body is
art to me showing off my body is not
about being sexy
it's about being and feeling beautiful
there is so much aesthetic with the
female frame i'm obsessed with that
sometimes it's
abstract art and beauty i believe in
being confident in every form the very
next slide
is swipe up for my only fans you [ __ ]
fraud
[Laughter]
tell me if i'm wrong why can't she
accept it
it's like a fish that's trying to walk
on land why is she
so she thinks sexy and beautiful is two
different things abby she doesn't want
to be
a [ __ ] but she is no no no no no you're
saying she's a [ __ ] because of the
pictures
no i no no no but i don't know how many
guys she [ __ ] i can't say she's a [ __ ]
but that's that's not saying that's a
sex worker she's a sex worker you're a
you're a sex worker you are
selling sex for money right yes
is it sex yes it sucks why is it sad
maybe that penis is not going in
exactly you can't say only nudes is for
sex workers and then when someone's on
only news selling news you'd be like
that's not a sex worker
[Music]
everybody says only fans is for sex
workers it's a safe space for sex
workers and then when somebody tries to
go
that's not a sex worker they're like
whoa what are you doing you're [ __ ]
up the space for sex workers none of a
[ __ ] is selling nudes
on only fans how's she not a sex worker
and i'm okay with you being a sex worker
i'm okay
with you objectifying yourself i'm open
this is not only am i okay with it i
love it
i love to take part in that relationship
this is beautiful
you're the flower i'm the bee
i gotta pollinate you isn't that what
they do
i'm not going to really do it of course
not you know what i mean
back in the day
you got to get some pollen in your nose
god bless you yes he did
some people getting corona out here
[Laughter]
so my point is i'm so upset with the
fraudulence it's art it's first of all
let's talk about art
art is an object to be objectified oh
[ __ ] what do art
what do we do with our we look at that
[ __ ] and judge it
you are calling yourself art you're
calling yourself a [ __ ]
object oh you're acting like art is
better
i don't beat my dick to art
[Laughter]
jackson pollock looked like he bit his
dick on his heart
that helped maybe that's her point real
talk
maybe that's her point i just think it's
absurd
and it drives me crazy and it's this
[ __ ] where like
you think you're above the thoughts
you think you're one step above a
thought because it's art
no you're not you are one of
and that is fine and accept it and love
it
[Music]
if somebody won't tell me oh yeah you
just tell dick jokes
yes i do
love it happy to do it hey you're not
gonna find me all i do is
intellectual social commentary [ __ ] you
suck my dick
[Laughter]
it might be part of it but i'm a thought
for this comedy baby
we laugh thoughts yo we laugh laughs of
course
but now it's 20 20. you understand what
you could be doing with your time
instead of being here
you understand how good technology and
entertainment has gotten
right now you could have sex with your
phone
while you lay down in the back seat of
your self-driving car
while your dog is in the driver's seat
wearing sunglasses
cruising around just [ __ ] freaking
people out
but now we're gonna watch this and look
here's the thing
when i first found out about this this
is a huge honor to be here i love
everyone that works at comedy central as
a comedian
this means a lot to someone to like be
on the show
but like my honest to god first thought
was like oh yeah it'll be great to do
this taping
because then i can get a clip up on
instagram
that's what this art form has become do
you understand that no one's even
watching specials unless you're like
dragging trans people be like i gotta
watch that because i'm gonna need an
opinion
the only thing that's it
that's honestly it and i'm this is not
anti-comedy that i'm doing because
nothing is more embarrassing than
anti-comedy that's like a comedian that
comes up who's like well
actually cooler than stand up oh cool
guess who else is [ __ ]
everyone you can't even admit to
yourself that you want to
do the embarrassing job of stand up
that's like the person who wanted to be
a singer but now they bring like their
own cds to karaoke
like who maybe put this in
[ __ ] admit to yourself you want to do
it it breaks my heart cause i love this
thing more than anything okay i
fly away from people that i love so i
can do this job
and instagram clips you understand what
that means that means now as a comedian
we are we are competing against for your
attention we're competing against
instagram but models an impossible task
just like like you're looking at like a
picture of someone's like open birth
canal like make a nose take me back
and then it's my [ __ ] well-crafted
joke from eight months that's what
that's what we're competing against
i do love though on the instagram but
models like post
there'll be like 400 horny guys
commenting right
but then there'll be that like one like
[ __ ] white knight
that's gonna let her know like he's not
like the rest of the guys right
so he'll post something and not give us
like uh a nice pic but actually like uh
what book you read
cool man throw her off the scent let her
know that i'm not like into her like
her boobs me but also like her mind's me
or this i don't need to have a joke for
this you shouldn't do this on a taping
anyone watch it but like what's that
thing where like this is like a new
thing where like
like a new mom with a baby she'll she'll
make like an
instagram for her baby and then all the
other captions are from like the baby's
point of view
[Applause]
who is the why what who is that for
it's like a photo of like a baby covered
in chocolate and it'd be like
mom said chocolate was gonna spoil
dinner
why which one of you is that for
i understand look [ __ ] i under like it's
deeply sweet but it's
so creepy it's kind of same kind of like
creepy and sweet as like when like
pornhub
around december will like upload like
christmas themed porn
and you're like oh wife
is that for who it's like jizz the
season
what who the [ __ ] is
anyone in this room like uh jerking off
feels great but what's the theme
[Laughter]
so i'll leave you guys on this with your
guys's help because that's what the art
form has become and no i'm not cooler
than it i respect this more than
anything
i need the perfect instagram clip so i
need you guys help
first thing we need is uh for the camera
guy are you you're in the wide
can you frame me with enough headroom so
i can put an embarrassing
meme like title above me it has nothing
to do with a joke it's just like that
moment your mom makes your ex be
homework
and then and then we'll put two very
low-res
emojis above me you couldn't get the
rights to this fate
so and then we'll leave some room for
some for some embarrassing subtitles
because you know nothing's funnier than
reading a joke i'm not laughing what's
wrong oh
oh okay yeah at that moment that [ __ ]
slaps okay
i'm laughing
and then i need the joke itself it needs
to be like very broad
something that anyone could come up with
like vegans suck or gluten free people
and and the visuals of the joke it needs
to stand out on your scroll
so i'm going to be very physical so
don't be thrown by the fact
that the visuals will have nothing to do
with the joke itself
okay and the last thing i need from you
guys and
are you on there does anyone have a
camera facing this way
last thing i need from you guys is from
the dawn of time comedy central will
always do this one thing where
they'll cut to someone who's really
enjoying the set
right on the level of just like tom
cruise i have all the adderall and money
in the world
and the person right next to them is
this guy
who's actually sleeping right here
and it's like why you guys are here
why'd you come to this guy who's
actually sleeping no no no no you go
back to sleep go back
i need you
it feels very weird but you need to go
back to sleep
so you go back to sleep you guys are
killing it so the punch line will be
um the punchline will be let's see
that's like swallowing the needles so
when you hear that's like swallowing the
needles
you go crazy you go back to sleep
okay so remember physically not going to
match the joke itself uh what happened
to gluten in this country folks
[ __ ] gluten oh my god folks
gluten is by no means a poison or a
toxin
all it is is it's protein and it holds
foods together
so what you have to do when you bake
gluten-free is you have to add more
sugar and more fat
so so you're not actually being healthy
you're not all you're doing
is you're taking out two seemingly bad
ingredients
and you're adding two even worse
ingredients
it's basically like saying oh i'm
healthy now i don't shoot up heroin
now i just swallow the needles
[Applause]
thank you please subscribe
[Applause]
yeah and then all like the uh i've seen
the new trend is like the like
beautiful women that have like millions
of instagram followers just because they
post swimsuit
you know photos and stuff like every
three weeks or something you have to
post something about the
the stress that they went through like
when they were like i've been judged on
my appearance so many times
we're feeling ugly i was called ugly
when i was younger welcome to the
[ __ ] club
right and it's like what your whole
business is just that you're hot i know
i was called ugly and i am ugly yeah
exactly
i couldn't even show them
exactly i was accurately called ugly
right
it's humiliating i was called ugly my
comeback was
fair enough touched
show your eyes work
you know what's with those instagram
butt models i follow many it's weird the
guys who like them
why do you have to click just enjoy it
oh yeah they
do you want attention i guess i don't
know they don't know there's the
they're hope to pull you out of their
depression with their sculpted ass
they're going to back it into your life
when the sun's going to start shining on
you
they're going to scroll through their
likes they're 10 000 likes and find
that one yeah that was a nice guy he
liked me it's hope it's like the
stripper the guy the stripper guy was
like she likes me
well people go crazy online like any of
those pictures if you start reading the
comments
guys will be leaving comments like grown
men
that are like oh oh i love you're such a
beautiful spirit
and oh it's another great photo but i
really love you too i love your
personality we should meet you
they want to be special i'm special it's
just it's it's
mental illness i see you through that
piece of thong between your butt cheeks
to the to the you're the soul the person
that you are
that's right i saw it through your anus
i saw your soul through your anus
like a telescope i looked up through
your [ __ ] and saw your heart saw your
soul
yeah they say the butthole is the window
to the soul so i saw it
it's beautiful one thing i will say
about butt models they promote each
other
they're so generous they promote each
other like you got to check out my girl
kiki but you know how the group does
that you know that's clicky you know
there are bump models
that have been cast away from the other
butt models i think that they've always
been more
like open than titty models tv models
are very uh because they're not
in right now right they're not in tits
with like tits of the 70s
yeah 90s they kind of went with those
big balloon tits right they used to have
with
the [ __ ] almost look they had like
bloodshot eyes they were so stretched
out
it was like three feet in between they
just jumped the shark there was like no
way to go with that so then it became
about now it's about the ass
yeah you know so they're all supporting
i do like that though not not a
giant giant but i do like a nice fat
trump's the best
yeah but the asses have gotten so
ridiculous and big like now it's like
they're it's the same thing that
happened with fake express the fake
asses the best
yeah have you ever felt one you can tell
when you feel a fake
yeah you can feel it it feels it's a
harder it's soft
but it's almost like remember how
stretch armstrong used to feel like that
that toy
yeah that's what it feels like specific
yes wow
no i just love it it doesn't move with
the legs it's just
it's just it's sitting there like a
lunchbox a lunchbox you want to [ __ ]
right yeah right it's just
it's just i don't there was uh where the
hell was it i think it was in a gym or
something like that i saw
one recently but i saw one out here
surprised me there's a lot of them in
l.a
yeah more more so more so in like you
know uh uh
miami tech like dallas miami in orange
county is where i see the most
uh um extracurricular uh
so is that what you're doing on the road
now now that you've kind of been into
every like
sports stadium you've seen all the games
now it's like i need to i need to
monitor the fake asses in each city
no i just noticed uh like uh
when i was in dallas it was just every
bartender just had these giant and they
were like tear drop shaped titties i was
like what is in the water out here and
like someone's like nah man these are
most of those are fake they just do so
many they're really good at them
in dallas and dallas yeah and then uh
arizona too phoenix women
huge yeah really yeah yeah so orange
county was like
that was the one where the guys was
crazy like they had the
remember bruce jenner remember that guy
sure what happened
yeah i don't know i haven't seen it from
it it was good well they uh
they had like the eye lift that [ __ ]
going on like the uh
where everything just looks like uh yeah
you were like in a wind tunnel or
something like that and i remember
because my wife watches all those real
housewives
i used to think that like okay they just
took an extreme version this is not an
accurate portrayal of it and you go to
orange county it's
obviously not everybody but it is it's
just it's a
noticeable enough segment or maybe
because i watched the show with her i
i i noticed when i walked by i was
playing the uh the improv in irvine
you know i was walking between shows i
was just walking through the mall or
whatever
and i just i saw like three or four guys
that just had that that bruce jenner
[ __ ] yank back
kind of thing going on there so i don't
know i don't know why you would do like
i think you just you look so much better
if you just kind of roll with your
genetics yeah it is what it is
it stays even right you know what i mean
where it's just kind of like uh
no those places on the face you can't do
that's like jane fonda looks [ __ ]
amazing
but then there's always going to be that
one spot where you're like ugh like
whether it's right around the eyes or
the neck there's always something
horrifying that ages exactly like it
should
so 90 of the face looks good but then
there's that one part where you're like
oh [ __ ] that's an old lady the lips are
tough
the lips give it away they lose moisture
oh [ __ ] she's one of the andrew's
sisters
[Laughter]
but that it's i mean it's the same thing
when you see guys to get like hair plugs
for everyone that goes really well
you see a guy like i saw a guy walking
down the street the other day and he had
buzzed his hair
but you could tell the whole front was
plugs and it was
don't you love that i love a horror show
of pear plus
yeah i do how old was it because it
depends it was it was
real they were really really really
[ __ ] bad they were getting but now
that they vacuum you
first of all used to get the big smiley
face right now they can just sort of
vacuum the [ __ ] out and put it in and
then it takes for some people and it
doesn't
for others but they're trying to say
like um
uh someone's telling my podcast because
i'm always like threatening to do it as
a joke you know
and um they said that like that stem
cell [ __ ]
if you shoot in the top of your head so
i was joking because i'm gonna do this
eastern european tour coming up in
january
that i was gonna go over there and find
some transylvanian doctor over there to
[ __ ] shoot it and i was gonna come
back with the redhead version of like
farrah fawcett hair
and i was never gonna address it just
coming back
shaking my head before i spoke on
everything he wasn't that he wasn't old
enough for it to be bad he probably just
didn't want to spend a bunch of money
yeah no it's it's
stem cells do it too they have those uh
they should they do those facials
where they call vampire facials i don't
know if that's stem cells but they shoot
like you're
they do something with your blood and
they put your blood back in i think it's
uh a lot of whatever the [ __ ] is in
platelets and then they shoot it into
your face and oh yeah young people's
blood some sort of fetus involved
no yeah they just musher fetus and they
melt it down and shoot in your face
but no it's your own blood you know when
they make avocado you know that bowl
they just
have a fetus in there you got to drink
it and shake hands with the devil
to look six months younger dude people
are out of their [ __ ] crazy do they
do it into your face and they're
supposed to be very good for like
wrinkles and moisture or whatever but
it's obviously well jim i gotta tell you
you've kind of been reverse aging man i
mean if i look at some of the pictures
of you from back in the day like yeah
you were uh
hideous yeah he looked like a beat cop
oh gosh come shoot jimmy then you
started doing the pull-ups man look you
know a wrinkle on your face
yeah my face is held up okay and there's
other things that have made my face
wrinkle-free is that right yeah caligula
was right it works
and not a drop of booze either no that
helps not smoking i think quitting
smoking helped a lot too in 2001.
yeah oh i forgot you smoked i smoked for
17 years yeah and i couldn't when you
quit
that helps a lot you see guys that smoke
when they're 50
yeah i mean the benefit to uh never
being
uh attractive is that when you start to
fall apart it's not like it's a
heartbreaker yeah no one no one says hey
what happened to sam
exactly that guy fell off yeah it
doesn't doesn't matter that's the thing
about all those beautiful peoples
that's what like the ugliest people in
the world would say [ __ ] like oh my god
did you see so-and-so what the [ __ ]
happened to her it's like the same thing
that happened to you
you just you just fell off a curb right
so nobody heard you hit the pavement
yeah i mean it's the better it kind it
gets you like later later in life is
where it starts to reap the rewards but
no matter how mediocre you are you
or you look you always feel it like i
look at myself i'm like [ __ ] you put
weight back
whatever it is you still like you know
it still comes out yeah you're a
psychotic you eat like a tiny little
candy bar and you look your gut like oh
my god i'm getting fat again no but you
know it's just the way you look at
yourself
he holds himself to a higher standard i
don't feel it's good for you oh no i
didn't
shame him he is shaming me i don't like
it i just jim has had
food issues they are shameless as far
back as i have known
and it's so brave the way he judges
himself after a three musketeer
mini the fun size that's
it's about brave positivity